veteran organizations gathered in
boulder city for a wreath-laying
ceremony joe mueller was at the memorial
day weekend event today he shows us why
veterans say it's so important to them
[Music]
while many people have memorial day up
and perhaps are having a barbecue
veterans we talked to here say they want
people to remember those who paid the
ultimate sacrifice
it's important to me because
the people that gave it all it was a
gathering to pay respect it's to honor
them to remember them arrow is the
president of the vietnam veterans legacy
motorcycle club a lot of people think
it's just to
start summer start a barbecuing but it's
it's we're able to do that because of
who made the ultimate sacrifice every
year hundreds of motorcyclists joined
for memorial day drive before joining
other veterans at the boulder city
veterans cemetery for a wreath-laying
ceremony this is
a real good ceremony for us that we do
every year steve warner is a member of
the special forces association chapter
he says people at home should recognize
the day and the meaning behind it to at
least take a moment
and
think about
the the reason why we're having this
this this holiday weekend this long
weekend even if it's just
you know a little moment of silence of
your own kent helen is the chapter
president of the special forces
association a local group of special
forces veterans you can tell there's a
lot of fallen here at the cemetery a
visit to the cemetery is a way many pay
respect he says while people enjoy their
day off try and remember those who lost
their lives i have friends that are
buried here so
it's very important to remind people of
that
joe muller live local now
tomorrow's memorial day ceremony is
happening at one in the afternoon at
southern nevada veterans memorial
cemetery if you're heading out make sure
to get there early to give yourself time
to find parking